for me sakes a light beer a light beer
that's the one unforgivable sin right
there the one unforgivable system I got
you I'm just joshing yeah yeah but
seriously get me a porter at the very
least that and then you have these
people who come in and go well Jesus
came out to hang with the sinners well
here's what here's what bother bothers
me about that you're misusing the term
sinners because every single person
including your Saints including your
priests including the Pope are Natur
everyone's a sinner a horrible Center
every single person so when you say that
if you mean Jesus came down to hang out
with everybody well sure because
everybody is a sinner what they're
trying to say is Jesus came out to hang
out with came down to hang out with the
lowest of the low well no that's not
necessarily true he did come to reach
the unreached that would be the proper
way to phrase it okay
so he came to reach the unreached but
then people say a lot of young people
say well I hate so they hang around
people who are doing drugs making bad
decisions ago I'm like Jesus I'm hang
out with them with the sinners I'm gonna
reach them okay know Jesus said this is
whether you're a Christian or not I'm
just talking about an analogy here Jesus
with these people with tax collectors
prostitutes interesting that the Bible
by the way puts tax collectors on the
same playing field with prostitutes I'm
very happy about that he said hey follow
me go and sin no more right so he came
and he reached those people he reached
the prostitutes he reached the tax
collectors and they abandoned it to
follow him do you really think Jesus
would have been buddy-buddy drinking
beers with someone who is still a
criminal breaking the law you think he
would have want to wanted to be around
them and associate with that no they
were welcome to join him and abandon and
be forgiven for their previous
lifestyles do you think though he would
have drank beer at all yes
he drank tons of wine well I know about
the wine but I need a beer always seems
like it would be that's a cultural thing
now okay that's even one thing if you
look at I was reading some training from
old strongman books and they will say
you know like this is the lifestyle one
must live you must train hard but it
must not be too strenuous you must sleep
well one must not take strong drink but
their lunch was like for cakes and five
ales as they
they didn't even consider it strong
drink they were thinking of like Jack
Daniels or some other thing yeah I mean
I don't know if Jack Daniels was around
at that point but beer was like tea you
know is just what you drank so yeah I
definitely don't think Jesus would have
had a problem with people having a beer
- I mean here's a thing - with Jesus
when you're talking about that people go
well well line with really more like
grape juice back then well how do you
stop fermentation of wine cold
refrigeration so they had no
refrigeration so you know it was a
better stronger yeah it would have had
to ferment until you drank it and not
only was Jesus there with his first
miracle turning water to wine you
understand the context of the Bible read
any any books or verses that talk about
weddings in the Old Testament it always
talks about overflowing with wine not
some people did lots of wine at a
wedding so they anticipated this this
was a big wedding and they still ran out
of wine after they had drink they'd
consumed so much wine that they ran out
and Jesus still turned water to wine
anyways why in which in its history
that's a guy to have a party there you
go that's a guy who has a party and
again in its historical context wine
that all in all likelihood was stronger
than today so we're going to we're going
to get letters but Christians who try
and say the Bible condemns any kind of
consuming of alcohol clearly have not
looked at at Jesus and and what he did
he kept the party going in a sensible
way cool guy drank some wine louder with
crackers if you like this video watch my
last one otherwise you might be held
down I'm just kidding you just what it
is it is a good video